quite a week in Washington so let's take
a look at all that with Sabrina Siddiqui
a political reporter with The Guardian
Sabrina good morning good morning let's
start with the attack on Syria and what
kind of response is that getting in
Congress on both sides of the aisle well
unlike last year were there was
widespread support expressed for the
president's action in Syria when he took
similarly retaliatory strikes against
the Assad regime's alleged use of
chemical weapons there's a little bit
more of a split in Washington somewhat
predictably along partisan lines you do
have Republicans expressing support for
the president's action but Democrats
many of them are arguing that he needs
to come to Congress for approval first
these are some initial targeted strikes
but there's a potential to draw the u.s.
into a far more protracted conflict and
for that he would need a new
authorization for the use of military
force that would be passed by lawmakers
in Washington we also know turning to
another topic the president's personal
attorney Michael Cohen is under criminal
investigation what do we know about that
what do you see this going well this is
one of the more complicated matters for
the president because Michael Cohen is
his longtime attorney and we've been
looking at allegations of potential
campaign finance violations or even bank
fraud that were made in relation to the
hush money that he had paid to stormy
Daniels a six-figure sum that obviously
is now well known there is also an
investigation into his business dealings
including a taxi medallion business here
in New York I think more importantly the
question is where does the president
factor into this he was on the phone of
Michael Cohen just yesterday and if
Michael Cohen is under criminal
investigation he could be under
surveillance and so what conversations
has the president had and what legal
peril could that expose the President to
at a time when he is already of course
contending with the separate Special
Counsel investigation into Russian
interference in the u.s. election you
know New York Times is reporting this
morning that aides to the president see
this as a greater threat to the
president and the Moller Pro it could
well be in part because we don't know
what conversations the president has had
with Cohen who has acted as his longtime
fixer according to a lot of people in
Manhattan trying to
help him he describes himself as he
describes himself as a fixer trying to
help do away with anything that may shed
cast a negative light on the president
and you've seen apparently uh that he is
willing to pay to do so I think that the
question is whether there are recordings
between Michael Cohen and the president
he was known to record a lot of his
conversations as well as whether it may
well be over a lot because anything that
the US Attorney's Office would uncover
that might relate to the investigation
into Russia could be referred back to
Robert Muller and his team and so this
could be a lot more complicated even if
it seems like two separate issues in
this moment what do you make about the
pardoning of Scooter Libby what do you
think the message is here that he's
trying to send well I think there are
some who have interpreted this as
possibly a message to those who have
been indicted in the Muller
investigation to hang tight they don't
cooperate with the special counsel that
the president may have your back if you
are Paul men afford if you're some of
the other individuals who are facing
some of these very serious charges I
think that there was also a little bit
of a nod to James Comey an effort to
poke him maybe a little bit because he
was the Deputy Attorney General who
appointed the special counsel at the
time who prosecuted a Scooter Libby
there is of course it's escalating war
of words with Comey and the release of
his book so the timing is very suspect
especially if you look at a lot of the
harsh words the president has had
against the former FBI director sabrina
Siddiqui thanks so much for being with
us this morning thank you